in storytelling especially in film a
visual medium
it is show not tell people don't take in
information
or they take it in much better if it's
the information
is in service to a story that uh touches
their hearts
and um so the you know science tells us
that the most
effective storytelling is one one that
um is is is human-centered around people
people we care about we identify with we
relate to
um and um we release oxytocin
when we watch something about someone we
care about and that is
the love hormone it it's it's what makes
us
um feel um attracted to somebody it's
it's the hormone we secrete when we kiss
when we breastfeed when we have sex when
we hug when
when we and then like videos of our kids
as like the woman
exactly you feel warm and fuzzy it
actually changes
your body chemistry and then the story
needs to be
structured in a way where there's some
tension and rising tension
and if so that's what captures our
attention
and holds our attention because we
secrete cortisol
and cortisol is um it's a hormone that
is from our um the amygdala the fear
center
and um it's what what um
heightens our attention um so if you
have rising
tension in a story and you have people
who are relatable
the cortisol grabs the attention keeps
your attention because
i mean we're in an attention starved
world but even before social media and
all these
other things our brains are prone to
wonder but you want someone engaged
so it engages our brains it engages our
heart
and then after if if i believe strongly
in structuring stories that well the
classic story structure
from like ancient times to today is
there's someone that person has a goal
there are obstacles in the way the
person has to struggle to reach the goal
we have to understand what's at stake
the bigger the stakes the harder it is
to reach the goal the more we identify
with the person and
root for them the more we go on that
emotional journey with them which is
actually
um if you if you um study people's
brains
when they're hooked on a story they
actually their brains
um act like a participant not a
spectator
so you can actually bring someone on an
emotional journey
and then if you end on triumph they
reach the goal you leave your viewer
feeling
wow i can do that too um
and then it also releases dopamine which
is kind of the reward
center from the reward center of our
brain so it leaves us feeling optimistic
and hopeful
so um that's that is like so it sounds
like you start with oxytocin
and then you get to cortisol and then
you hope to leave them with dopamine
right but you and the way to do that is
to
um tell stories about somebody
the viewer cares about whether it's the
candidate
uh telling his or her own personal story
where we care about the person um
and that person's struggle
it could be personal struggle it could
be struggle of
why they care so deeply about why
they're running or a certain
issue and then ending with a sense of
hope
because if you leave people with no hope
then they're not going to feel like they
should take any action because if
they're not going to be able to achieve
their goal then why bother
you know you want to and which is one of
the criticisms you know i had
and like i struggled with we've all seen
those cheesy political ads
it's like you know it's a black and
white photo and it's like i grew up
like uh you know the the son of a
cobbler
or like that the daughter of a
thatcher or what you know i mean i make
that up because i don't think we have
thatcher's anymore but
it's like like where where you make the
person relatable
and then like you make it seem like they
overcame this hard scrabble
background and then like you have some
uplifting photos of them
you know like i personally have lost
patience for
those political ads and i know when you
and i
talked about this stuff like i i
struggled a little bit
with trying to convey things in a way
that felt
personal to me that just didn't feel
like uh artifice
or it's like okay hit this beat he hit
that beat
because i feel like at this point people
have just lost all patience with
political
ads and communication um but it sounds
like the things you're saying appear in
a lot of these political ads so
do political ads look the way they do
because they work
well i don't i don't know but i think
that execution
it's always the devil is in the details
right it's
like what i'm laying out you can like
any story you can execute
well or you can execute poorly so
cheesy's horrible out there like yeah it
sets out to make a bad movie but there
are a lot of bad movies that get made
sure and it's not pink by numbers it's
not
like there's no formula to follow it's
really
about for every single person finding
what is most
genuine to them um but that doesn't mean
cheesy and cheesy cheesy is how
something shot
it's the music it's the graphics it's
cheesy is um you know it's a quality
and so i think that um
uh you you know you
you want the um the feeling of a video
to reflect
the identity and feeling of the
candidate
not to because everything again this i i
hate the word authenticity because it's
so overused
but like you that is one of the many
reasons andrew why
you broke out because you didn't you
didn't study what do other politicians
do and how do people
running for office how how am i supposed
to behave
you didn't do that you were you you
always showed up as
you um well one thing that we found
uh early in the campaign when we were
shooting various videos or appeals
where the most effective appeal was just
me talking to my cell phone camera
um i think because of what you're
describing where
it strikes people as very
genuine and human because everyone talks
about their phones
and so it seemed like you couldn't fake
anything
and i think that that's something i've
seen
with younger political figures
yeah where they seem really good at that
right you know i i'm not sure how
excellent an instagram soliloquy
deliverer i am
uh you know in the scheme of things like
uh but i i agree that
just giving someone a glimpse into um
your moments on the trail or your uh
you know like home or whatever it
happens to be
uh like it makes them feel like they
know you in a particular way
um i think if a politician was not able
to do that
um then it there it seems like there's
something missing
well i you know aoc's launch
uh video was brilliant um it wasn't
hugely polished but that didn't matter i
mean in terms of how it was shot
it actually probably was helpful that it
felt so real
um and it was it was everything i just
described in terms of
you know uh her her struggles her
journey her why
her you know her her being relatable but
it was you know um not cheesy there was
nothing
cheesy about that video so it's it's all
about the execution
um uh and and people being vulnerable
being themselves i mean you know you you
sealed
even studies about leadership and what
builds trust and what builds loyalty
among a leader it's if that person has
credibility
and then that person is vulnerable
and and and shares that they're fallible
or that they're scared about something
or that you know shares
human emotion that we all have
then people see that person as human not
super human you don't want to be seen as
superhuman
because then you don't seem approachable
you don't seem real most people probably
would like to be seen as superhuman
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you